special effects is no longer a regular  annual award it is given only in cases  where the achievement is large enough to  merit recommendation by the special  effects committee and approval by the  board this year such an award has been  voted it goes to when worlds collide  paramount  and walleyes in the house are waiting  and waiting for the head of paramount  studios mr. wife Frank Freeman to make  his appearance on stage and receive from  this valley far as reward is premium by  the way the fashion knows who's wearing  he's now accepting the award from his  forest and will speak I accept this on  behalf of Gordon Jennings and the  members of his organization that worked  so hard to accomplish this award thank  you